hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to capture now available
okay ah I just got in this oh this oh
this is the menu oh [ __ ] I it was a
start but okay alright yeah you know
what I'm not gonna go back we're just
gonna plow right through hi how's it
going my name is markiplier and here
we're gonna play a horror game by the
name of captured that's supposed to be
pretty dang scary and right now we're
all cheese oh okay I'm gonna make some
predictions we're waking up on an
operating table
we have no memory of who we are oh jeez
oh god this is legit hello I probably
shouldn't shout
maybe you are underground you have
fallen into a hole I don't know Harper
in the forest overhead you are now at
the start of a series of chambers down
here
I can't land it'll game progressed to
the next each activation lever is escape
you see down here there's a man who
wishes to cut you up you lady's name is
Damian Clyde and he is blind but he
thank you I'll be on the lookout for
Damian Klein who wants to cut me up and
eat me
why does he want to eat me I don't know
what happened I was what I was in the
forest what I was just going for a jog
and I fell in a hole I ended up on a
bloody bad
I'm sorry I need to take a minute oh my
god because I was tossed in here in the
most literal sense of the word and now I
need to find a lever to escape a man by
the name of Damian Clyde who wants to
eat me okay [ __ ] and I need to not make
noise coz he is blind and can only hear
me so hard oh jeez
okay alrighty then alright I'm gonna I'm
gonna expunge the bitchiest nature out
of my body go in - bad bad bad mass mode
badass markiplier mode also known as bad
mass mode and find a [ __ ] lever Jesus
god damn it is it the toilet
of all places what does that mean all
places to be oh here we go didn't you
open up your private collection here
okay so what do I do I do
so can I open that again just a little
bit can i oh can I get another speak Pig
of it so okay did I do that I didn't see
anything was there a lever there I can't
see I can't see a [ __ ] thing tonight
okay alrighty then alright trusting the
ominous dark hallway I'm sure this is
gonna oh [ __ ] why okay you know what
hang on i Griffin [ __ ] hell I'm
having a bit of an adjustment issue I
I literally sprinted into this game and
I have no idea what's going on flagging
find out that you're barefoot this is to
balance again in your favor
surprise
[Music]
Oh God don't look at me like that
put away put these away the [ __ ] do I
probably have to throw something to
didn't go anywhere
I am super wimpy okay oh god oh god okay
thank you for the constant reminder that
death is looming around the corner okay
so there's two levers one opens both
gates one opens gate and exit so I need
to find two and not get the wrong one
wiser why is there a little toy
why why why is there a seesaw horse and
a beer bottle I'm trying to understand
the conjunctions here between these two
dissonant head they're diverting a bit
items whatever the word was okay there's
one lever here one lever in there and a
lot of blood on that lever which I don't
know why there's that much blood I don't
know
okay right slap slap me slap swoops up
September [ __ ] you hey Clyde damn in
plaid DC do you mind of call you dick
[ __ ] I don't know okay alright can I go
for this one now in the room the blue
[Music]
even constructed these cancers his
system showed contempt didn't like his
appearance his demeanor they were only
here to hurry and finish the job and
then receive their payment and get the
hell out people are greedy greedy little
[ __ ]
[Music]
but with your why is it my choice why
does it have to be my choice of course I
want to save them I just have a funny
feeling I'm not gonna be able to if
Damian Clyde is in the room with knife
all right all right don't worry bucko
I'm gonna call you Smith Arun or you're
about to be blown into that but either
way I'm gonna try my best to save you
your head no gonna be crushed don't you
worry about a little baby thing so we
got three wheels [ __ ] I need to not do
that hey I probably should have saved
that ah yes I'm an idiot so there's a
lever in there and love in there I'm
assuming that that lover that I'm
looking at right now is gonna start this
whole endeavor and not just straight-up
kill him so let's try this oh hi
hi okay don't mind me
he's gonna go cheese Oh God oh I need to
hurry oh I need to hurry okay [ __ ]
hell
oh Jesus okay I'm I'm there's no [ __ ]
way he's not gonna let me go [ __ ]
Jesus I can't do this how the [ __ ]
able to do this oh he loves me Oh God
he's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
I can't possible
[Music]
[ __ ] are you kidding me that was
impossible
how would in the vlog I mean it's like I
said I didn't think there was gonna be a
way to actually do it there's no way oh
geez what is this oh god this it's not
exactly the best there's only one tiny
tube of antibiotic and tube bandages
heals one hit okay great
oh goody oh goody goody gumdrops what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] there another
lever in here
is there something by the dead bodies
does this mean something it's as a
pattern I'm guessing I got to hit the
buttons in a pattern point okay
boink boink boink boink boink boink
smart cookie I'm very smart I know I'm a
very smart guy right jeez it didn't even
give me like a tutorial on this [ __ ]
of a [ __ ] wheel like look at this
[ __ ] where am I supposed to turn this
[ __ ] down and oh I'm supposed to go
down and then around
this what is this there's no way if I
had to turn it that much the whole time
there's no freaking way that would have
ever worked for three of them no way he
was and there's no way to save him it
was just a matter of if he wanted to
pull the lever and then get I don't like
this [ __ ] is that okay I don't know what
this is oh jeez I don't like this all
those mannequins is from my mannequin do
it I'll [ __ ] you hi how are you doing hi
hi friend
are you Clyde is that you Damien okay so
gotta start from here go around oh hey
hey buddy how you doing oh this is not
fun place to be
oh hey you look like you got arms oh
geez so if I'm not mistaken I gotta push
the buttons in order okay weird oh this
was the last one no that not right can I
do that right okay so it must be the
number of white things on there I
believe this is the first one even
though it's at the end of the arrow
because it's a shortest and there's one
two three four maybe five but I'm gonna
assume not five and then assume that for
that one so one two three four cuz
there's a chair hidden back there then 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 7 8 and 1 there's five
bodies so 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
does that make sense goddamn it you can
only go up to 11 so one of these things
is not like the other
Wow
I don't know what I did I did five seven
and 11 which I suppose is good that
ominous music isn't good
[Music]
funny [ __ ] ketchup
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] give it up
minutes give me this give me this give
me this give me this give me this give
me this [ __ ] [ __ ] Jesus Christ okay
so I got through that yeah I guess oh my
god okay that was like the last part was
mostly like guesswork because I didn't
know exactly what I was supposed to be
doing but it still was not bad at all
that was that wasn't not bad that was
good that was legitimately good this is
the start of something good it had good
graphics I've had good ambience it had
good atmosphere animations a good
villain good challenge to the gameplay
of it good moral choices that were so
conflicting I don't know if I could ever
be able to save that dude unless I was
just whipping my arm around the wheel as
fast as I could but maybe you guys can
do that yourselves I'll put a link to
the game down in the description below
and thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought of
this down there in the comments because
holy [ __ ] this was good so thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
[Applause]